BEAR GRYLLS: OK, Rob.
Your front points--
your crampons
are your main
weight-bearing things.
Good lord.
BEAR GRYLLS (VOICEOVER):
Comedian Rob Riggle and I are
in a race against time,
searching to find a case
of supplies before nightfall.
But first, we've got to
scale this mountain of ice.
BEAR GRYLLS: So you're
watching the black ropes.
We're not kicking into that.
Oh, it's a long way down.
Looking at this, it's only
like a 30 or 40-foot ice climb.
But it's what's behind Rob.
There's a 150-foot deep crevasse
that I can see below him.
[panting]
BEAR GRYLLS: Take your time.
That's good.
No hurry.
[blowing]
ROB RIGGLE: OK, come on, Rob.
What was the one lesson you
learned from basic training?
Slow and steady wins the race?
Never quit?
There you go.
That is you.
You never quit.
Looking really good.
Finish strong the last bit.
[panting]
Well done.
OK, keep using your points now.
You can stand up a bit more.
Well done.
All right.
That gets your sweat going, huh?
[laughs] Good job.
It was a good climb.
That's a great motor.
It's a great motor--
it's a great motivator
having a 150-foot crevasse
right behind you.
That kind of gets
you up the hill.
Crossing these things
is always such hard work.
It's like, you know, 200 meters
in a straight line, two hours,
you know?
Exactly.
Well done, mate.
Thanks.
He's panting.
He's sweating.
He's done well.
We're at the top.